jay-z always grateful to him for
coming out and making that song for us
you know he didn't have to do that i
know he's a busy guy
billionaire actually they say jay-z is a
billionaire
i think he'll be a billionaire someday
me i think you'll be the first youtube
billionaire
i don't think i could handle it i didn't
ask if you could handle it
jay-z always grateful to him for coming
out and making oh no we have double
audio dance panic
it was you you you i already muted it
like i didn't do anything oh
who did it who did it
it was [ __ ] i'm sorry i [ __ ]
up
i'm sorry oh my god
[Laughter]
at least you owned it that would have
drove me crazy
i was being blamed otherwise my
sincerest apologies
i got zach over here with the stream
open i got a b with the
[ __ ] ads going off nerf commercials
tell you what anyway thank you for
joining us you know we missed a week so
it's good to be back two weeks here
two weeks gone and it's nice to see
everybody
um a lot's happened in those two weeks
you know
frenemies is going wild you know i've
i'm working on a
i'm working on a special episode for
monday
um i'll say it [ __ ] it what the [ __ ] do
i care
well it's not scheduled yet yeah i know
but i'm just trying to make it happen
i'm trying to get you guys to know dr
drew
i'm trying to get him he's he's a
therapist
and i'm trying to get him to come on the
show and mediate me and trisha
for monday it's going to be awesome
apparently he's down so
we just got to get his ass in down here
you know
what the [ __ ] brought to you by somebody
oh we have a sponsor today
sponsor today's sponsor is harry's
razors
gary no harry oh i was like gary doesn't
have razors
aries gary's razors we love you arie god
damn it
[Music]
um you know we made a video uh about the
quartering a court a content court
and um this is the first time we made a
content court where somebody kind of
went ballistic
so that was fun you know i gotta say i
think we did a really good job on this
one
we spent two weeks preparing a b
was in the trenches doing all the
reconnaissance
and everyone kind of just worked hard to
put it together we had this beautiful
powerpoint
and uh the quartering did not appreciate
our work
do you believe that ela he was not a fan
he called it low effort
oh um but i will thank first of all
jeremy
for becoming a sponsor he joined he
became a football
he's a football trooper he says it right
here
he became a fupa trooper so he go watch
our [ __ ] so apparently you know
thanks for supporting the channel
appreciate that in my basement he just
peed in his basement
that's the best sound bite zach please
for me one more time
i just peed in my basement
yeah here's some tweets he went out to
me
so he made a whole like immediately as
the video came out
you know i put it out for members in
that case
and uh and then he immediate he made a
video to it
like an like an hour after the members
version went up
i was like what it was a two-hour
podcast and so
i just posted immediately cause i was
like well if he's gonna be talking about
it on his channel
i might as well put the video up because
he was just saying all these outrageous
lies to try to rile up his
fans he was like ethan attacks my wife
relentlessly
and well here he goes yeah
that was his thing he kept saying is
that i i was relentlessly attacking his
wife
which obviously something that we didn't
do and wouldn't do
so i immediately tweeted at him hey
because every single comment was just
like all these people from his channel
being like i can't believe you would
have saw his wife
when you made you know you have a wife
and how dare you and you made a big deal
about keemstar insulting your wife
so i said hey the quartering can you
timestamp me where i insulted your wife
i will apologize and remove it from the
video
no time stamps after all that
he responded ethan i appreciate the free
promotion and you're concerned about my
dick size
and sex life and lineage of my what the
[ __ ]
by the way lineage of my family i think
that's in reference to
his three gay dads two of which are
black
is that really lineage lineage is like
heritage isn't it
yeah and also it's a lie anyways so what
is he talking about
how dare you accuse him of not having
three dads
he says this video is defamatory and
desperate
you you and i both know that if you are
anyone else this video would be creator
and
creator
has been a strike you've fallen so far
[Music]
yeah he says this a lot too that if it
was anybody else because i'm the chosen
boy of youtube
my video would be removed even though
cue hardcut crash cut
can we crash cut to uh
where's that one tweet by con comment
cop
can you highlight it maybe yeah or just
bring it up here
yeah i am on it so then the other thing
was
here crash cut to jeremy the slowest
crash gun ever
yeah slow-mo crash cut
oh look how i like dude i really got
under his skin i have to say and i feel
bad for
i do feel bad because this is a dude who
pees in his own basement and
isn't married in seoul
holy [ __ ] h3 productions uploaded a
[ __ ] two-hour video about me well
it's a podcast it was not like
a video i mean podcasts are generally
two hours that's another thing
yeah like people always uh they always
take the liberty to confuse the podcast
with a video
yeah it's a two-hour podcast dude it's a
free form conversation
i feel personally harassed i have zero
time to respond to it
two [ __ ] hours again podcast but
anyway
he's made like 20 videos about me
honestly
it's not about that i didn't even bring
up
it's the uh three stooges sound effects
because he's a buffoon he's a goofer
you know it's not about any of these
videos he's made about me
um and that's why i didn't bring up any
the fact that he's even made a single
video about me in the podcast
i just think it's funny that he cries
that
oh if it was anyone else your video be
removed and meanwhile
you know 20 videos
so shout out um
on another note luke is asking
my girlfriend is laughing hysterically
and wonder why you didn't just cover
your eyebrows with makeup
whether watching me right now oh instead
of shaving lol
because it wouldn't look as good it
would not look as good and you know that
and your girlfriend knows that
because if you get some silly putty or
whatever they do it just doesn't look as
good
and i'm gonna be honest with you guys
i've kind of enjoyed walking around
without eyebrows and hair
first of all my hair grew back so
freakishly fast
it's only been like less than two weeks
yeah and
i feel like my hair is back to normal
the eyebrows were coming back were
lightening quick
but we had to shave them again on monday
or the jeffree star one
but it's already coming back too but it
was kind of nice not having eyebrows i
don't know why i was just like [ __ ] it
dude
it's like i feel so agile you know i
like the look
i think you look badass
people are wondering if i've been out in
public yeah oh yeah
i don't care i don't even think about it
i go outside i mean we went on a
vacation right after shaving the
eyebrows
i'm in the lobby checking in i'm not
thinking about it at all
you know what i mean um what's in your
smoothie
i don't know okay just answering
questions
i have no idea
[Laughter]
it's good though so anyway um
can i explain why i'm so dead just so
people know you sure um
theodore's been going through sleep
regression i think i just realized
and it's just all of a sudden one night
this week it started
on monday he's been waking up in the
middle of the night and
not sleeping through the night so i'm
just
so dead this night he woke up at 12 and
then at four again
yeah this whole week's been brutal
oh yeah he's been he wakes up at like 2
a.m and he's like
ah and it was
like i'll pick him up and then he was
holding on to me like
there's no way to put him down it's
really sweet on one hand because he's
never hugged me so tight and it's like
precious
but then you realize that he thinks
you're gonna like dip him in lava or
something
by putting him in back in his bed
and you just gotta leave him there right
that's what you're supposed to do is
spend some time with him
say hi let him know everything's okay
you have to otherwise you'll never learn
i mean i put him down and then i stayed
in the room at least i don't know i just
i can't so i spend time with them until
he knows it's
okay until he calms down like 15 minutes
then i
put him back and he [ __ ] think and
it's the word but you gotta just
you know last time i did it i did it at
12 and he fell asleep yeah
he fell asleep that's how you got to do
it
this isn't my first rodeo it is actually
but thanks for saying that so anyway
i says can you a time stamp where i
insulted your wife nobody was able to
provide his time stamp
right he says well it's a hat he says
thanks for the half-assed apology i
didn't apologize
i literally didn't apologize he's like
the way that the quartering talks about
things and this is why i made the video
to begin with his video of his reaction
to my video
was full of literal [ __ ] lies that
all of his
audience took as fact and if that's how
he argues and presents everything i mean
here he says i apologize
no and then he says you called me a
white supremacist
and a pedo and so i was like oh okay so
i didn't insult your wife
i just called you a white supremacist
pedo so i go back again i said hi jeremy
can you timestamp me where i called you
a white supremacist or a pedophile
i will gladly erase it and apologize
no time stamp provided either by the way
oh starkel says he did provide his
timestamp where yeah he ultimately did i
just i just put the tweet in right here
um
next to the comment cop one oh really
this is exciting let's see that's right
yeah he's oh that come on that's a good
time
stamp are you really trying to
this is in reference to the pedophile
and waste of premises all right can you
give me the actual time stamp since he's
uh like inept because i need to click
something i'm not going to go
i mean i remember you made a joke when
because we were talking about him
that's watching all the magic people of
being pedophiles let's watch it
because he's he's what he's insinuated
here is that
is that he says
i lost it
oh here not for [ __ ] sake
dead air trying to find this
you all got together to celebrate two
guys butt [ __ ]
right jeremy that's a totally normal
thing to say
no he says he issued me a half-assed
apology
after calling me a white supremacist
and insinuating i was a pedo you got
some time stamps for me
for christ's sake that's the 48 30 the
first one he's referring
referring to okay here we go everyone
gets excited
yeah i was a member of that community
for years
uh here's his tweet on sleeve media is
that it do i need to go back more
i got a file he got banned from magic
the gathering and then tried to run a
story about how they're harboring
pedophiles
right he's like i know i am that
pedophile
is that a serious insinuation that he's
a pedophile
like seriously dude talk about a little
snowflake trigger little [ __ ]
like are you really gonna act like in
our two hour long
podcast full of hard receipts and and
like
and like our claims are it's based all
on p empirical stuff
is he gonna cry oh well i'm not gonna
contest any of the actual stuff i'm just
going to find this one time where he
jokes
makes an obvious joke an unserious
joke and be like he called me a
pedophile it's like nah dude you peed in
your basement bro
that's literally you got cocked by your
wife for pizza and peed in your basement
i mean really that's all it comes down
to
my basement
come on man you got more time stamps for
me ab
yeah it's right under it 5139 that's the
second time stamp you provided
okay great let's see
puts his views on mr weinstein's alleged
victims
and that adults who made choices and why
he's tired as a white man for being
blamed for everything that's wrong i
remember what happened
round of applause
there are how many victims in harvey's
life and i feel sympathy for them
but hollywood is full of very ambitious
people who are adults
and they make choices if you re read
between the lines here what he's saying
is
people knew what they were getting into
when they serviced
the man and is this it maybe
these are what he provided these yeah
these are already provided yeah
i'm pretty sure he's accused of rape
like i think there's two
issues here that he's not a oh so he the
second time stamp didn't do anything
he's got a quarter of opinions the
quartering
my opinions are half fake they're only a
quarter ready
you know and then the other thing is he
says i called him a white supremacist
and he didn't timestamp that but
let's be honest that's true he kind of
is
you know what i mean he's not going to
contest that one yeah he's like well
yeah that's kind of the point of my
channel
yeah i am of course a white supremacist
right he said it himself you see that so
anyway that was fun
i welcome the quartering you could be in
discord right now
as a member all right probably is and um
he made this whole video i kind of i
don't know if i are you guys interested
for me to watch
no no no everybody says no
okay all right well you guys ready to
get weird and wild and terrifyingly
awful let's do it
welcome to after dark everybody
i'm hesitant to even go to this place
because it's so
disgusting oh no i feel like it's too
early
what else do we have in the show or
something this wretched
the pimple yeah we'll do it live
save it for a little bit uh yeah it's
too early it's gonna make a bunch of
people bail yeah
i guarantee people are gonna bail when i
when i do this
so let's just wait a little bit
um man you guys seen
everyone's probably seen this but people
wanted us to react to it
so i am your faithful servant oh go away
go on creep me out
no go away what is this like what what
kind of animal is this
no it's a mountain lion oh wow those
those are out here in like los angeles
what is that that's what they do
i think he's just he's juking it you
know
by the way i love how he tells the
mountain line [ __ ] you dude
like he just lost beer pong to it holy
no it's so wild you dude i don't think
the mountain lion wants to attack him
what i heard what i read in a comment is
that he probably came near their nest or
something
so she just wants to make sure he [ __ ]
off away from her babies
yeah that's what i remember but yeah
this is [ __ ] terrifying
i wouldn't even know what to do in that
event look at her she's just like keep
walking [ __ ]
do you know where this took place nope
colorado i believe colorado stupid kitty
cat utah
stupid kitty cat kitty cat bro your life
is in danger
and you just call it a stupid kitty cat
holy crap kitty cats that ain't no kitty
cat i never made it to this part i guess
holy come on dude i don't feel like
dying today
yeah he's keeping his [ __ ] together
pretty good
[Music]
no go away that that guy's a legend i
mean this guy really
no what the [ __ ] he really held it
together i have to say
no do you think what would happen if
that
mountain lion wanted to like attack him
um i think he would have lost that
battle
yeah definitely
it was utah by the way gosh you think
you
you guys think that you could battle a
mountain lion of this size because what
is that mountain lion weight like maybe
80 at most probably less oh
that's a good question i don't know like
if you're jacked like a big-ass
bodybuilder or just like a martial
artist you could probably [ __ ]
you could probably i mean you would take
some damage right
but you could probably [ __ ] it up i
don't know
it looks pretty scary to me about lions
range between
64 and 140 pounds that's not 140 pound
mountain yeah i would agree it's on the
smaller side yeah although it's
kind of hard to tell from stuff and
video 140 that's huge
that would kill me yeah do you remember
the story in colorado when the dude
fought the mountain line off with his
bare hands it was like a few years ago
yeah i mean if you have no other choice
i mean i'm not strong i would die but
like if i
was more confident in my physical
physique because you could like gouge
its
eyes you could [ __ ] tear it at its
legs you could punch it for christ's
sake just give it a punch
in the face man you know what i'm saying
yeah his hands are
knives though so it's kind of
it's going to [ __ ] you up pretty quick
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah damage yeah yeah
yeah yeah
right no you would you would you maybe
you would probably
sustain some serious damage and possibly
death you know
but better than a bear a bear a bear
would just there was actually someone in
the chat that said
they used to have to walk near black
bears on their way from school
black bears are pretty as i understand
it not
aggressive relatively docile yeah
they'll still [ __ ] you up if they get
nod though yeah yeah yeah but they're
not aggressive like
it's not like a grizzly bear bears are
terrifying dude
bears are scary you wouldn't wrestle a
bear
i'd wrestle you if that's what you mean
yeah you stupid kitty cat
can you imagine and you're facing like
death and that's what you say
you must be christian or something you
know i mean they're so conditioned to
not curse oh you think so you freaking
kitty cat
i didn't it is your turn so what are you
supposed to do in that situation
look as big as you can right
make lots of noise don't act scared of
it i think you are supposed to back away
slowly
don't turn your back to it yeah don't
run he handled it
pretty much ideally how you're supposed
to maybe throw rocks at it i don't know
i think he did it right you don't want
to bend down because then you're
vulnerable
yeah for sure he did throw a rock at it
towards the end of the video
yeah it says online do all you can to
appear intimidating
wave your arm slowly speak firmly in a
loud voice
[ __ ] that dude
i'm [ __ ] out dude
someone said i ran away as a kid and ran
into a mountain lion in the middle of
the night
and they screamed like humans it was
terrifying the mountain lion screams
like a human
their scream is [ __ ] terrifying wait
i gotta hear that
it's [ __ ] horrifying
it's terrifying mountain lion screaming
now this is why we're here
what no
oh my god
oh [ __ ] yeah that's blair witch project
what
wait doesn't that explain like every
horror film in the woods
[Laughter]
[Music]
the wave finishes off i bet that's a
human being
what nightmares come from dude
you know you got the mountain lion and
then you got you know
they're
this is my favorite video when i was a
kid this is one of the first internet
videos and i would just
yeah sure i would just listen to this
and just
laugh and laugh and laugh sometimes
we're good huh
yeah and then of course there's the goat
um goat sounds like usher
which you know there's so much ice in my
water
it's awesome what else did i want to
hear
screaming i sent one [ __ ] scream
oh dude i don't like this already
dude a lot of noise screaming and stuff
now i hear something in the woods
walking
i don't know what it is
that's freaky
this isn't the best video is it here
screams of the red fox if i saw
something right now i'd probably piss my
back
what
i just peed in my basement holy [ __ ]
poor jeremy got so scared he peed in his
basement
[Applause]
oh my god what's with all these animals
sounding like humans well get out of
here
they sound like women too
i've been playing uh by the way people
like to know what video games i'm
playing
um hayes
officials at customer games awesome yeah
it's pretty cool i was playing in some
more last night
that's some video a witness shot as it
happened the custer county chronicle is
reporting
it all started yesterday even when
evening when a woman
is she's so close to the buffalo aren't
buffalo super aggressive
buffalo are super aggressive and
absolutely terrifying animals
they're tasty
man conquers nature zach the fact that
someone like
zach can just go and they're tasty
talking about like this
absolutely brutal ruthless terrifying
monster just a testament to how
we've dominated this earth
can you imagine zach if you had to
actually kill a buffalo to know that
i'd dead spear with my bare hands you
would be talking a lot different about
that buffalo
motorcycle and approached a buffalo calf
an adult buffalo charged her catching
her belt
on its horn and then oh not the bell her
around violently which you can see in
this video why are you all hanging out
with buffalo man look at this
and she fell down oh she had no pants on
she was flown to the hospital but her
injuries were serious injury's not
serious
hey here's an idea don't go play around
with buffalo
it's like look at all the buffalo yeah
why are they even there
they want to be like zach it's tasty
they are tasty
um someone said koalas sound like
they're burping really loud
let's go koala screams i'm there
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] world star
world star oh
they're so cute my god
it doesn't sound like perfect but i'm
really enjoying this
dude this wallet just punked his ass
yeah
why you play your homie like that
there's only like two of you left in the
world
[Music]
oh it's like a baby yeah up the man up
back in the tree for christ's sake
this is so so wild
yeah he's not having it he's like could
you just leave please
um
i felt something tickling my ear i have
a feeling i'm not gonna like this one
no what is that all right let's just do
it
i absolutely knew i could feel something
tickling my ear oh what is it oh my god
[Laughter]
what is that it's a giant spider as
spider that size
oh my god oh
god it's your his home now just let him
be
yeah just let him be oh my god
uh i'm pretty sure i would cut my ear
off
something was tickling my ear oh what if
you laid
eggs in your ear i'd be like obsessing
over it yeah
oh man that's awful you know i get that
singing goat stuck in my head like for a
week oh
oh my god
animals huh they taste great but they're
also pretty cool
not to eat love me some buffalo dude
look at these vultures they just claimed
this [ __ ] house
it's like a scene out of rick and morty
there's just one house on the block
covered in vultures oh what and
god's green [ __ ] earth and why are
they doing that with their wings
okay end of the world love you honey
they are all oh
okay
[Laughter]
all right peace out earth
with peace i am telling earth with peace
and love
it is time to surrender earth to the
vultures with peace and love
peace and love peace and love and love
i am warning you with peace and love i
will be leaving this earth
uh already what else we got do you want
one more
koala sounds compilation
uh how can i well sorry what how am i
gonna watch koalas when you got this
yeah that's pretty epic that that one
wait what is this janitor life hacks
macgyver
oh my god
[Applause]
what is the deal with this guy clearly
uh funny
but he's also pretty old
[Music]
what's really [ __ ] well yo
how i feel like why don't we have air
powered mo
i guess it's really loud i'm just
wondering
i guess that's how airplanes work idiot
well they have jet engines did you shoot
air out bro
badass dude someone said this has to be
in florida i think so too
that is correct it is in florida yeah i
love
the audio there's no sound there's no
[ __ ]
it's just a dude
and a mop bucket
yeah he's a hero we need to give him a
battle
what somebody just throw [ __ ] at him i
don't think it was
adam was just throwing [ __ ]
i don't know it's a football yeah he's
just [ __ ] around
cool you want another koala one i don't
think so i get it they just okay they're
just crying little babies does anybody
know what this message means ethan dr
disrespect talked about the parking
incident on stream today
the parking incident what is the purpose
what is happening with
the dock he's just a youtuber now really
yeah and there's still no news about
what happened there's no news
is there ever going to be updates about
what happened to him
you know does he talk about it is there
like well you gotta imagine
it hasn't been long there's probably
still litigation happening
yeah he he just he made a a statement
somewhat recently where he's just
saying that he's sad about it and that
he doesn't know why and
um it's hard for him to get over it
but there's been no no sub substantive
update
i truly have no idea what that means
yeah i'm not
saying anything about it um
someone said you got mad at him about
taking your parking lot or something is
this just
i got mad at him for taking my parking
lot
did you have a weird dream that you that
sounds like a weird dream
maybe it's just supposed to be a made-up
funny story okay
you said you were mad about him taking
your parking spot i
that's something oh i think well if doc
i think maybe he was just making a goof
yeah that sounds like a doctor
disrespect goof yeah but i'm happy that
uh he's mentioned me
what the [ __ ] is this something insane
[Music]
what holy mother of [ __ ]
you're all good dude just keep cruising
this cheery music
highway robbers take shots at moving
trucks
wow wow that guy needs a raise dude
[Music]
i wonder what you think is really
you know i wonder if there's even
anything valuable in the truck you know
it's just like a bunch of
my pillows or something
[Laughter]
my pillows no they want the cargo
they want the cargo i would assume no i
think they're well maybe
they may just want the truck they just
want the truck yeah
where is it it's well who knows what
they want
i think they want the my pillows that
make a lot of sense
[Laughter]
that my pillow guy needs to take a
[ __ ] vacation i'm sick of seeing his
ass
i'm sick of seeing his dumb commercials
you know i thought about buying my
pillow at first because i'm like in them
always in the market for a good pillow
and i read the reviews and they're like
it just sucks
the pillow sucks it's not that good it's
right it's
awful oh you you got it huh
that's funny you returned it
yeah i did so wait it's like not it's
like only like 1999 so i mean good
pillows cost more than 20 bucks right
but you get you go okay
you go this guy's got like a pillow
empire there must be something to this
pillow yeah
but i don't think there is
zach did you call the number on the
screen no i got it
and how many nights did you sleep on it
before you returned it
i [ __ ] tried it out for like maybe 15
minutes i'm like this [ __ ]
sucks i'm not sleeping on this
and you got a full refund wow yeah dude
why
why
would my pillow be in that truck well
they got to ship them somehow
i was just saying like maybe you br
maybe you go through all this trouble
with guns and [ __ ]
to break into a truck and it's like what
am i going to do with a thousand my
pillow
nobody wants this [ __ ] to begin with
it'd be hell of an ad my
pillow dot truck oh
[ __ ] dude
who sponsored us again my pillow
[Laughter]
my pillow
[Laughter]
listen i wouldn't do a good read for
them i'd be like mypillow.com
zack hates it some people like it
it's only 20 bucks and you can return it
if you don't like it yes he's his own
spokesman he's on tv every
[ __ ] 10 minutes yeah that guy really
is a
he's a [ __ ] workhorse a pillow all
right harry's razors
we love harry's razors you know they
have like brick and mortar stores i saw
wow so is there a guy named harry or is
it literally just to play on words
because like
hair hairy you know i mean like is there
a guy named harry or what i don't i
don't think there is
it's founded by two guys named jeff and
andy so oh
i want a better lives
all right good name yeah i like it
you know i was listening to uh i have
some tips for our
listeners i know it's mostly male not
all but
uh women like a well-manicured penis
and so i was listening to the pretty
penis howard sternus having this
contest called the pretty penis contest
and i think it's just important for
people to know because when i was in
college
i never manicured my pubes
for whatever reason but like manicuring
your pubes is very important
yeah do you agree ella yeah
so i think harry's is probably a good
place to start
new us customers can redeem a harry's
trial set of harry's
by going to harrys.com h3 you get
everything you need for just three
bucks dude damn close
shave smooth glides affordable prices
convenience of ordering online
let's talk about harry's it's founded by
two dudes named jeff and andy i guess
they're upfront about not being hairy
who were tired of overpaying for razors
they thought most big brands were over
designed overpriced and out of touch
so they founded harry's as a return to
the essential
quality blades at an honest price as low
as two dollars
per refill quality german
engineered blades harry's founder wanted
to sell products they would be proud of
so they raised a bunch of money
to buy razor factories in germany that's
right why germany
what do you mean are they german german
efficiency my dude
yeah oh okay you think they're just
they're out there cranking out blades
it's a quality product
yeah i don't just get a little ptsd
talking about german efficiency
excuse me it's been honing precision
blades for over 100 years
they sourced their steel from sweden oh
so exotic
and owned the entire manufacturing
process from r d to the factory floor
this allows them to keep the prices low
harry's is delivering their sharpest
shave ever
and they are not raising prices their
new blades are so
sharp that [ __ ] guys shaving two four
times per week
reported that harry's new blade their
eighth shave was as smooth
as their first beautiful
it doesn't dull not even i wonder if my
hair
i don't know my do you think i have
thick facial hair
not really i've seen worse they
confidently stand by their blades with
the 100
money back guaranteed on harrys.com
harry's is now available wherever you
shop online or in store
harry's has a great offer for our
listeners new us customers can redeem a
harry's trial set
at harrys.com h3 for just three dollars
you got five
blade razor featuring their new sharper
blades a weighted ergonomic handle
foaming shave gel with alloy and a
travel cover to protect
your aloe aloe aloe
alloy is a metal right yeah there's some
alloys too
aloe aloe vera and a travel cover to
protect your blades when you're on the
go so guys
if you want to support the show and get
some beautiful raises in the process
just go to harrys.com
h3 and redeem your trial offer today
thank you all right so
um let's watch this she's here to help
oh did we watch this didn't we no
did we watch this last week we did yeah
yeah
yeah yeah she gets in and crashes his
car and he's like what the [ __ ]
yeah we saw this
um where's ian he's editing
oh yeah we shot a um we shot a
among us with duncancino video game
donkey
his wife leah eddie burback
and gus johnson and the whole gang so
there's 10 players this time
and uh should be a lot of fun so he's
working on that
why are these guys so casual about this
they're like we gotta get going
whoa thanks really
oh my god hang on hang on i gotta watch
that again there's something weird about
this video
this seems like a fake i mean i know the
video is real but it seems like they
faked the situation but who would fake
turning off their engine in there
yeah that doesn't seem funny at all but
it seems like he's on the verge of
laughing doesn't he
maybe it's just in there is nervous
reaction though we gotta get it going
because i don't know how would you fake
that i mean there are
well if they're like experienced airmen
mm-hmm and they're just but it seems a
little risky for even a guy who's goofy
something very weird about this video
you know what i'm saying yeah i kind of
do
and why was he like tethered yeah
we got to get it going yeah we do i seem
really calm
people saying it malfunctioned i don't
know there's
it's fake but it happens more often than
you think it's still a badass video
that happens more often than you think
of people still flying that [ __ ]
yeah it's like part of pilot training
they're saying yeah i'm not flying
i'm not [ __ ] flying that
sorry ag happens
[Laughter]
would you uh would you ever like take
flying lessons or like try and
fly a plane or is that just an immediate
note for you
for ethan yeah yeah i'll tell you it's
an immediate note for him
how much more clear do i need to make
this
[Laughter]
well that's that's that's [ __ ] you dan
no bungie jumping
no parachute i thought i used to want to
be like
into that stuff when i was a kid but
then as i got a little older
my interest in doing any of those things
totally diminished
like i'll just go on a roller coaster
you know
if i want a little thrill in my life
golf cars through a swamp
oh you're about to hit it
[Laughter]
oh my god
that's a [ __ ] spotter right there bro
oh my god god damn
i just still driving i know you felt
that face lifting up
i was underwater bro you're telling me
wait what
where's the deep spot oh you're about to
hit it
oh he's trying to do this he said
where's the deep spot at
oh boy
oh my god turn to the right right right
his homie's just dead
yeah that's a [ __ ] spotter right
there bro oh my god
damn all righty
sorry what the [ __ ]
man these people get up to some weird
[ __ ] in their free time dude
any comments or donate don't knows you
want to read off um
i think someone said about that airplane
video
it just the joke is that they're so used
to it oh
so it is a joke but it is real
yeah i mean i have no doubt that the
engine was stalled like you could see
that the propeller wasn't moving
why would you go back in the air after
that happened even one time too
you know what i mean like i mean you're
gliding at that point it's not like you
just fall
the edge is going to turn back on uh
well a lot of people
some people die adrenaline i don't know
you think they're junkies adrenaline
junkies
could be
so you would never go skydiving no
holy of [ __ ] and an [ __ ] you watched
this
no what is it
even what wait is that it's going
so these guys knew that something was up
too what is the speed is this a scene
from speed
like what is happening if he goes below
70 the bus blows up
oh my god oh
[ __ ] dude these guys knew something was
up way ahead of time yeah
wow god jesus gnarly dude
um you want some comments yes please
so um someone said they design guitars
what did you say i don't know i'm i'm
not sure like what you read here
this person is designing guitars and
they're asking if there's a teddy fresh
email
i mean you can always email support
teddy fresh
um i was just in isolation because i
have coveted on campus at college
very scary week i have some good poop
stories thanks to corona
peace and love others corona poops okay
what
well then then has anyone actually died
from corona
good question maybe one maybe like a b
can look through the comments and see if
there's anything
yeah it's kind of hard to sort it
while we continue to watch i'm looking
at the donations you want me to read
them up
yeah all right my uh girlfriend is
laughing hysterically oh wait we ready
right now uh i uh
game gamer said i'm deeply adore your
laughing video with the firefighter who
threw the fire all over the random times
it's always bright my day i love that
guy man that is just one of the best
videos ever
uh ela uh where's your headband from
it's so pretty
it's from etsy etsy you see that
headband that is pretty bling though
that's pretty adorbs oh so you guys
wondering about our
attire teddy fresh teddy fresh
just came out yesterday yeah it stains
on you i know i was eating
like pizza and that's right
but you can't see it from that far away
uh
hey at least your hair is coming back uh
faster than keemstars looking great
keep it up everyone thank you switch
with
very hypocritical i think this is about
theodore crying
rub him with an egg he's probably having
nightmares and is scared to sleep alone
if not the egg just do something before
bed to comfort him what why would they
say to rug my child with an egg
why would you say that though why would
you say that
about rubbing him with an egg there you
go i mean i just read about it he said
rub them with an
egg what does that mean what the [ __ ]
i thought hard-boiled or soft-boiled or
really questionable well it's soft if
you're
rubbing is this a chicken egg or some
sort of lizard egg snake egg
lots of eggs what is it protecting from
ghosts or something yeah what is this
some super you rub your kids with your
eggs we'll rub our kids with whatever
that we see fit all right i read that
they go through slip regression and it's
something that happens at a few stages
and this is one of them
and did you not hear what he said rub he
said
people are saying it's a hispanic thing
egg is comforting
uh i've heard of it my stepmom used to
rub my brother with an egg
eggs are soft it's a hispanic thing a
lot of people are into the egg
thing but i don't know what kind of wait
wait yeah
i would like to hear more i'm just i've
never heard that and i don't understand
i would love to hear about they're just
saying it's a hispanic superstition is
what people it's like
a regular egg and then you usually like
they rub it down like someone's arm
but wait it's still like in the shell or
boiled egg
peeled i believe it's just a handful of
scrambled shells
like that with the egg yeah i guess i
could see it being kind of comfortable
should i
should we rub them with the eggs tonight
i could try it do you wash the egg
do you hard-boiled egg everybody keeps
saying it's a latina thing
you guys live in l.a i mean yeah i've
i've lived in italy my whole life i know
okay interesting you know what i'll try
it
because we'll report back why not we'll
report back next we're going to rub eggs
on our [ __ ] sun because it's just
common all right that's definitely rough
i guess you're right definitely wash it
because eggs can have uh yeah
right what else we got
i'm super broke this is all i can donate
aaron donate five dollars
but please please watch baby dynamics
yoga it's wild oh
no i know that i don't like that i don't
think i can even show it it's so
[ __ ] up like like well here let me let
me see
so these are people who do yoga with
like infants and super young kids and
i mean to me it looks like child abuse
and like torture and
but a lot of i don't know someone is
saying it's not a latino thing
so look i don't know like a million
answers that said it was though yeah
okay i don't know what it is but i don't
mind to try it let me see if it's uh
it's not age restricted so this video is
not age restricted but
it does have like a one percent like
ratio
jesus christ yeah i've seen this and if
you guys haven't seen this just get
ready because it is truly
[ __ ] i mean it's horrific what can i
say it's horrific
i don't think i've actually ever watched
it all right you're gonna you're gonna
hate it
okay get your get eggs out rub theodore
with some eggs
oh i have a while ago actually but
before we ever had a baby
[Applause]
wow no it's a real baby oh my god
this is [ __ ] insane that's not why
lena runs seminars teaching her extreme
brand of baby yoga
on the beaches [ __ ] i hate her
yeah i don't think she should have a
child they have to go to like a
different they have to go to like some
third
like [ __ ] like you know how rain
florence ran off to south
south uh america so she could breastfeed
her kid till he was 18.
so this is what they're doing like these
are american women
and like some crazy
you know south american town where just
everyone walk around to our own their
babies over their head like
glasses
[Music]
that baby is crying yeah i can't watch
it what else do you need
to hear look how happy this guy is like
yep
this is what we do down at b down corner
that's what it's called i don't know
what that is
it says bedouin i thought that was a w
like bedroom in israel yeah these people
ain't battling i'll tell you that
[Laughter]
even the better one no better than that
no there's nothing wrong with a better
one
what's the deal with the better one
because they live in israel i don't know
they're just kind of nomadic
right yeah they just live out in the
desert
yeah they do what a life
mm-hmm life of freedom you think they
think they do their babies like a
nunchuck they definitely don't
i have a feeling yeah throw them in the
air [ __ ] doing
crazy-ass tricks and catching them like
this they go like this
[Laughter]
yeah dude
so i guess it's a mexican thing i don't
know people
people are still debating about dag who
does that put an article in the discord
oh we got an article okay even those
were some uh pretty impressive stuff
thank you you're gnarly dude
all right we got info about the eggs
y'all
what does this say coranderus
uh yeah or oh curanderas like a cure
for real an old woman shuffles into her
bedroom dude
am i really reading a short story
trying to be entertaining here an old
woman shot here hit me with some like uh
some kind of mystical music or something
[Laughter]
an old woman shuffles into her bedroom
beckoning a little bit arguing in the
chats someone's saying
it is a mexican thing all caps and then
someone else
is saying it's not mexican well
apparently it's transcended the border
of mexico and america
i live in mexico and yes it is mexican
okay all right don't stop arguing guys
it doesn't matter it's just an egg
okay at what point
what is this turn that up is this
appropriate this isn't very mystical
this is someone that sounds like
jazz sack this is a myth
okay [ __ ] it let's go yeah
that doesn't work i can't even try
okay she's a healer she performs
curanderas treatments such as
susto where does it mention an egg abey
here i'm gonna i'm gonna do a control f
egg here we go
during our first olive uh virginia first
visit olivia passed an
egg dipped in holy water oh you guys
didn't mention the hole of water
oh ela was going to be over here rubbing
an egg all over theodore without holy
water are you kidding me it says
olivia passed an egg dipped in holy
water across the girl's body then she
cracked the egg into a glass of water
which revealed the girl had too much air
olivia said so
this is to be clear not the same thing
this is not what you guys are saying to
do to theodore right
abe are you sure all those things are
possible what the [ __ ]
what is this amy i couldn't find a lot
about it online but if you look here it
talks about the child becoming arable
and stubborn
after they uh they crack the egg in a
glass of water they can examine the egg
and tell if the child is suffering from
uh
oh so first you first you rub this oh so
it's more of a diagnosis
here my dad started from
shaman healers in mexico who would tell
what's wrong with you by cracking an egg
in water and reading it like that that's
exactly what we just read yeah that's
the real deal it's not just rubbing
things so
that doesn't sound like something i'm
going to be doing
well i'm fr i'm frankly just not trained
to read the eggs
so you know that matters
any other um any other comments
there's a lot of comments about this
there's like a whole debate
after you rub it you open it and toss it
into the toilet
guys you're not doing that this sounds
[ __ ]
insane i'm not doing that
okay when you rub the egg on his belly
crack it over his face
do him like a nunchuck use the eggs you
got from bella dolphin
yeah i wish those aren't real eggs any
other donations you want to read
yeah sure there's a i've been playing
among us with the name h3 ela telling
everyone to sub
well thank you i love the idea that
people are thinking
is just spending her free time playing
begging people to sub but yeah
she also she also said zach do you like
black seconds hit me up what
all right so what is the last term
blacks akins
black seconds like a black mexican yeah
sure why not
zach loves everything everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
let's fix it real quick what
oh my god yes
we're down there oh
[Laughter]
it doesn't even have a wheel on the left
side
[Music]
don't drive drunk people yeah i gotta
what did he say in the beginning reverse
so but he's just he's just a dude who's
like oh look at these drunk idiots
yeah oh yeah i don't know i guess
because i couldn't hear it
let me put on captions [ __ ]
i need a translation
did you just go get it can you still get
out
sorry can you still get it can you still
do stop
get it get it
the [ __ ] airbag went off and
everything
i love that accent could you still get
it get it
yeah it's pretty awesome get it get out
we got a lot of stuff today guys oh we
saw this one
dirt bike interview oh someone said just
waiting for a mate
it's one of my favorite videos
oh yeah we should watch that actually
let me watch that just waiting for a
mate
yeah yeah i love the australian accent
yeah yeah just waiting for a mate
uh uh drunk probably
yeah here it is what's going on
i'm just waiting for mate is that why
your car's all smashed up and you're up
on the grass
that he's you know he's even trying to
get his way out of it and he's dedicated
you gotta love it he's going in there
why i'm just wondering how how had the
collision with your car happened
what collision the one that's got your
all your wheels and stuff twisted up
bumper bars hanging off well
i'm just waiting for mate as i said
who's your mate
hi who's your mate james
james who how'd you get down here
how'd you get danny doesn't matter yeah
it kind of does mate because you've just
been involved in an accident
no um yes yeah what corner accident
one with a kid i think he's gonna get
out of there with the curb can i see
your license plate
no no no been drinking tonight so you
know in america he would be dead
yeah you got to appreciate how
like you know how [ __ ] up how
different it is in australia let's just
put it down
even if you're that drunk you'd still be
so afraid for your life in this
situation
you can't be like just waiting for a
mate yeah
can i see your license not like [ __ ]
clint eastwood can i see your license
now
[Music]
tank rolls in
he didn't have a license
that's perfect that's fine your car's
been involved in accident i believe
you're
you're an occupant of the car oh i
haven't even
i love it you're right
chapel legend
i'm sharply
i gotta go down memory lane
it's so cool that our shirt was in a
viral video
and like a really good one like it
wasn't you know how people go hey
he's wearing your shirt no this is this
is a really good video
this is the best shave that don't look
like you
it's a corky that don't look like you
it's the best video
that gets posted on our sub so
frequently
that's not your idea
he's such a good friend he's like dude
you're being humiliated
[Laughter]
how do you explain to someone that car
keys isn't their id
how high was he like i think he's just
so confused he's just black out drunk
god that's good not your id
tim mudd after this interview that's not
your ideas
[Music]
yo he could have not done that to her
right
[Music]
wow was she not supposed to be there
that's possible yeah
okay our next category is poop puke and
pain
i go here before this one sure
i got a i need to cleanse i got more
donations to read off go ahead
we have a 50 one from lame genie hey
guys we
uh put out a metal cover of the podcast
theme
oddly fits the feeling of the frenemies
contest podcast ask
zach about it love you guys so where do
i listen to it zach i'm supposed to ask
you about it what's going on yeah
uh i actually heard it it's pretty good
let's hear it too it is pretty awesome
pull that [ __ ] up here i'll keep going
while you're working on that uh
amanda says my job got shut down for
covet again i'm an artist i would love
it if ela would look at my paintings
at uh
epic moo
on instagram sorry it would lift my
spirits to show her my style love you
guys here i'll write it down
yeah we'll look it up by the way i got
this clip of doc apparently
talking about me rock when will you be
on h3 podcast again says donald
trump ron lear with the 499
[Music]
he's very thoughtful she's taking a huge
argument h3
and i
[Music]
i don't know if i should talk about it
that's so funny
[Music]
he's gonna give me so much [ __ ] for this
like so many people are going to think
that this is true and
start coming in let's see how
far-fetched his story is
all right it's too slow it's too slow
go ahead you thank you he was getting a
tunnel on why you don't feel good
hila's got a headache i'm gonna dm him
right now and say yo
let's come on the side of this beef good
deal i'm gonna deal him right now and
say let's settle this [ __ ] beef dude
dr dis respect
doctober yo let's settle this beef dude
settle this beef dude and come
on what is this show again
listen to this hey guys love the show i
think there's a bug
on the after dark sign any of you notice
how the curve
and cross of the h connects with the
three to make a wiener
the curve wait what [ __ ] say that again
it says notice how the curve and cross
of the
h connects with the three to make a
wiener
this you mean the wire i think he's just
saying the wire here
i think whoever made that comment needs
to go to the doctor i i i i'm sorry
uh corn and cob but i'm i'm not seeing
it
does anybody else see a wiener in the
sign let us know
i don't see a dick i don't see it uh
watch baby dynamic oh yeah we already
saw that
um we just put in isolation we read that
one too
what else we got
all right you guys ready for some weird
ass [ __ ]
sure all right
and by the way don't stick around to the
end because we have the weirdest
surprise
the most [ __ ] up actually i'll just
tell you what it is i'll tell you now
but i don't want to do it to the end
because it's so gross
but i'll do a little sneak peek for
everybody who's thinking about leaving
that should definitely stay
so we found this tick tock
oh we watched it in these times
discussion i can't i can't get it away
and we're like
well one of our chief questions was how
do they get a camera
inside of a blackhead sucker well then
we discovered that
for whatever reason a product exists
that has a camera built into it gross
right so that's what this is so we
actually have this
and with the camera in it and dan
figured out how to [ __ ] do it
into the feed so i can do it live for
you guys to watch
so you guys are actually gonna be able
to watch through the camera
that's why dan is a magician because i
don't know how you can figure it out
like by the way like a 50 thing
right i think it was even that much it's
like 20 bucks it's like 30 or something
okay this is a sucking device with a
camera that somehow
in its bluetooth to a phone and dan
figured out how to get this
into the [ __ ] stream for you guys to
watch
uh so could you actually like show yes
you want to see it
yeah well then we're just gonna have to
do it now
we're gonna lose all of our viewers no
just to see
through the camera yeah no i i you can
do it it just looks really shitty
it's like a mirror that's covered that
hasn't been washed
it looks amazing though that's like up
close okay so we'll wait
okay that's coming up coming up stick
around you're not gonna want to miss
that
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh gross i dropped it
sorry i dropped in the our chat how the
sign could look like a dick
yeah i didn't want to interrupt but i
was staring at it for the past five
minutes and i kind of see it now
they're saying it looks like a dick here
what did they miss
it's like abstract art i mean okay what
do you want me to do burn my sign
because you kind of looks like a dick
i don't see it even after saying that
low the balls are low
what's happening here like where's the
second ball it looks i mean let's be
honest
this is this this is a dick and then one
ball
yeah or this is the second ball but
that's not how you draw a dick let's be
real yeah so some people are saying that
they have crazy stories
uh about poop or about covet or whatever
so
i think they should just reach out to
zach right zack's the guy yeah
zack is the guy the gatekeeper dm me and
then
zach lets us know and then
makes it happen we decide that's why i
don't know what this is but
god help us iron stomach
shoe nice whatever this is
no wait what is down that's where people
puke and
spit and [ __ ] so they're having like a
chug contest and i guess if you have to
puke
you do it in there why does this exist
exactly college that's in college and
this is like an organized event
it certainly looks like here iron
stomach rules eat and drink what you are
given
if you vomit this is where you pay 20
000 a year to go to
college yeah sometimes more frankly or
more and a lot of times more than 30
000 so eat and drink what you are given
if you vomit you are out
the last one to throw up wins iron
stomach
i would love to see shoe nice in this
event
so this guy was like i'm so over it i'm
just so shocked by this event i can't
even
get past that it may not be college but
it certainly looks like it does but it
looks so organized
good he fell in the [ __ ]
wait he could just walk out it looks
like this guy's like just walk out
you could just walk out
that is traumatic that's horrific well
he
they say he was never the same after
that
girl poops in grocery store now we're
[ __ ] talking
you sent this one to me this is one of
the most terrific things
wow well you know we are continuing the
legacy of
people [ __ ] in the grocery store for
some reason there's
more than one there's like
this is our third video of someone
[ __ ] specifically in a grocery store
so
and this this one i'll admit is more
crappy than the other ones
what is she oh by the way really
she doesn't look like homeless or
anything this is sick she doesn't even
look drunk or anything
and she's kind of just like doing her
shopping it's so gross because she looks
so normal afterwards
you know there's bathrooms and grocery
stores
oh god someone imagine she she has to go
on a date
like i don't know if she's single or
married or what but like at some point
in her life someone's considered dating
her
you know it's so gross she's gonna touch
products after that and she just
oh no it's fine she didn't touch the
poop she's very close to it
yeah what is going on though why is her
hand there you got you know she pulled
her like panties to the side
diary it out she's pulling her underwear
to the side or her pants
right by the meat aisle bacon to eat
that food
[Music]
oh stall bro had a halloween video that
i wanted to watch
all glory did the stall bro he went
viral on uh
unfunny of all places 48 000 likes
lots of [ __ ] look at all the golds
wow so our boy stalbro is moving up in
the world i'm happy to say
happy halloween thank you
you're welcome hey bro
happy halloween on the other side
[Laughter]
oh yeah go ahead bro happy halloween to
you
you have another one if you want
you're welcome have you been like just
sitting
all day just
really is there someone you want some
candy bro happy halloween
you know one oh all right you know he
said that everyone on campus knows about
him so i wonder
if it's like a rare pokemon
but i'm happy he's getting all the love
he deserves man stalbro is a legend
i love this one this one really hit a
perfect balance of like how the people
reacted
i like how they just like take one
he joined my instagram live yesterday
and he was on stall
did he do the face reveal for you no i
mean i've seen his face but no he didn't
do it live
you've seen his face yeah yeah me too
how did you guys see his face
uh he messaged me on ig before about
yeah
yeah yeah oh but it's not public not
public now no
is he handsome tell me about how he
looks he's a good looking dude
i knew it i knew he was
i'm scared wait what
what just happened something terrible
happened
he got his legs in between he went the
wrong way
how did he hold on how did he get
holding on
how did he not let go what does that
mean it's like this
so he he dislocated both of his
shoulders
[Music]
how did he not let go yeah
i don't know i guess oh god yeah i think
that is what happened
just how did he not let go i'm just i
can't believe that i think
because his whole body just fell so
yeah i don't know but then he continued
to hold on even as he like
slammed down on the wrong way that
remind me another sport not to do yeah
right like my fat ass could even
swing a quarter way up stay off gym
equipment kid
he knew he [ __ ] up you should have
just let go
who should let go dude
let go god all right let's
do it
i'm just kind of trying to figure out
what happened
yeah this i saw this video i don't i
don't understand people
this is one of the things one of the
things that i just don't understand
oh wait what was he trying to try to
kick a knife
with a barefoot a blade
why and it went in his foot
which is kind of what you would expect
to happen so
um flavor lab said the black dot between
the t
and the e on the sign is bugging me
what is the black dot between them oh
it's a hole
it's just a hole in the wall why do you
guys notice everything we have to cover
that
well we're moving to jesus yeah can we
just like leave it
until we move jesus just watched that
thing again
well we used to have before we got the
neon sign there was other stuff here
that we
hammered in yeah so there's also this
hole in the wall
it's a stake in the boot there's always
people complaining about the uh
the screws that hold it up or whatever
yeah the little pegs
and they say get clear ones um a b was
supposed to wow there's like a lot
there is a lot of criticism about
ourselves i know and what i want to say
is y'all you'll find me some clear
screws
okay and i cannot find clear screws for
those you can go ahead and find me
they're very clear screws and not just
screws
because these are mounted screws you're
hired right yeah i have
yeah they're not just any screws it's
not just anything that's all i had to do
two pieces there's one on the back that
creates something to screw into and then
the screw itself so you need a little
two piecer
so um send that in i'm happy to buy them
daddy chill
i don't know but something's terrible is
about to happen
don't stand there
[Music]
it's a potato gun okay okay what could
go wrong putting oxygen and ass
uh acid tightly does it any chemistry or
know what the [ __ ] that means and a pvc
made potato cannon i think they just
shot down an airplane
anti-aircraft uh artillery
holy [ __ ] dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh jeez man oh man
oh it's someone wants you to finish the
dog video or you're interested
okay yeah it's just i mean he's just
sitting there silently yeah he just sits
there i mean i try yeah he just sits
there silently i'm trying to [ __ ]
have a show here not just dead eric
maybe you can timestamp me or something
a b because like skip to the end
or something let me take a look here you
send it in discord eb
yeah i sent it in this card let me try
again mangas got hacked breaking news
what does that mean among us got hacked
i don't know what does that mean do you
guys have any intel on that
all right here we go doc when will you
be on h3 podcast
again says final films rod lear with a
499.
he just he takes a lot of time to think
[Music]
this video is like we got the huge
argument h3 and i
people think i'm covering it up i don't
know if i should talk about it
[Music]
here while we're watching i can update
you guys on the among us
so it's dealing with a huge spam attack
where people are spamming the chat in
the game saying like subscribe to my
youtube channel
and like trump 2020.
i sent a picture of it in the chat and
discord so like in public games
the chat is just all spammy yeah i love
it
how funny okay
oh it's just one specific dude who just
trump 2020. that might move the needle
on the election
yeah it's the among us uh
demographic i had a beat off um dan i
have bad news for you people are saying
there's plenty of
clear screws on amazon great there's
plenty of them huh send me a link
yeah i mean i am seeing some money with
this computer
they're they're very specific they're
weird screws they have two parts too
thanks dan
yeah again it's not just a normal screw
you guys are triggering dan
dan is a perfectionist if dan can't find
it then something's up
okay we're at one i like it we're at one
minute in
he is still not said what's going on
lucas long welcome to the champions club
all right i'll talk about it
this sweet ass time i got to their
studio before they did
on the day of the first podcast i don't
know parking spot right there in the
front
lambo
secured the greatest spot in the entire
parking lot
because nobody's there
does it i guess he wasn't happy about it
okay
[Laughter]
boston ryan thank you for the 324 and
you know what
oh my god that's his [ __ ] problem
yeah no it is true the story is true
i keyed his car and uh it escalated from
there
you keep the lambo yeah i keep it all
the way down the side
i do that to any of the parks in my spot
though jeez mother [ __ ] christ
does he what was that
yeah i keyed his car so yeah i can
understand him being
upset about that
security footage of me taking a break at
work
oh boy
it was windiest yeah it was windy
hello you have to drop off at pandora is
the entrance down here
oh pandora they have moved on oh
what yo that's some
final destination [ __ ] wow why do trees
don't just fall over
for no reason there's no wind or
anything what the
oh god wants him dead that guy should be
dead he needs to die
i mean it is kind of slanted you can see
i mean
but yeah just looks like a clear
weather day
little breezy maybe a little breezy
holy [ __ ] dude
god's like um [ __ ] this guy
a tree's gonna fall on you
got so much good videos
where are we uh skidmark
wire and a sock the [ __ ] does that mean
oh god
whatever it is you know it was remo
whenever it's removed i go oh boy should
we not
how bad is this one i mean he's in
school how bad can it be if it got
removed
while it was removed by the moderators
it creates a spark
if i mean who gives a [ __ ]
oh that's not that bad why they remove
it maybe it wasn't long enough
that one bad bad
broken glass i saw that one not that
good
what are people saying let's see
howard stern what could go wrong
showing how to do the obstacle course
the teacher has shown seriously dude
uh that guy's awesome that's a cool team
you know he was just eating [ __ ] the
whole way
he may have planned that you know he's
kind of a goofball cool dude teacher
when when you guys weren't schooling in
class did you accidentally ever trip
your teachers
look like your foot was out in the desk
no what happened to you
i was i was in class i was in english
class
and i had my feet out and the [ __ ]
teacher walks by
trips [ __ ] eat [ __ ] on the floor oh
my god
there's coffee everywhere i end up
getting yelled at
did you didn't do it on purpose did you
oh but it was [ __ ]
hilarious man did you try to play it off
afterwards like you maybe did do it on
purpose to your friends
everyone would just start laughing in
class like i was so embarrassed though
man
being being a teacher sucks that that
really is a tough job
little [ __ ] like zach tripping your
ass i
had a teacher drop a chair on my finger
and broke my middle finger
oh so it goes both ways yeah how did you
respond how did you react
i didn't tell anyone i was such a like
scared little kid i just told my mom
that like i did myself
yeah you didn't even react well how did
you react when the
chair fell on your hand oh i didn't say
anything
she said she said sorry i was like oh
it's fine but then like i went home my
middle finger was like all purple
and then yeah my uncle's a doctor so i
went to my uncle's house and he's like
yeah it's broken
oh i can't believe you adored all that
pain without even like
yeah i was a very shy kid i like never
talked wouldn't you be like ah
it was in third grade you hold it in
yeah
mom anyone else have any teacher stories
someone is asking what the heck is that
hat zack
let me see zach i haven't seen his hat
what are you tripping on my style for
the ocean
go ahead oh i wanted to watch zach's um
yeah
yeah i got yeah oh yeah zach we have a
surprise segment
about zach speaking of zack's hat
here you put in discord yeah so zach's
been
active on social media
um
here hold on lewis l lewis
97 if you guys want to follow him and
all of his videos well the past three of
the ones that i've really
been enjoying are you in your car yeah
and there's a couple of things i wanted
to ask you about
first of all dude you're obviously
driving
and recording yourself at the same time
let me just mute it
you can see you're holding a phone and
driving that's not safe zach
why do you have to do it in your car
while you're driving well
that's fair enough it's not the smartest
thing to do but i was just vibing man i
was just feeling good
just straight up vibing man that's what
you think that looks a little bit silly
like that you're holding your phone
up but you can see it it's like on your
wheel
[Laughter]
when zack runs someone over that's
what's to the police all right first off
i it's not like i'm home
you'll see him coming in his glasses
first off i'm not like like on a public
like super public road it's just this
one road i go on
there's nobody ever up there really and
i'm just vibing wait so you're not
actually going anywhere you're just
driving around in circles to make this
video
he's vibing down yeah i hear a song and
i'm feeling good about myself and i just
feel like vibing dude
so the other thing is like you really
hang on this one wasn't maybe it's the
other
this one yeah this is the this is the
epic one
dude it seems like you're going pretty
fast bro i'm going
15 miles an hour no not this one maybe
in the other one
dude you were blowing it you were
[ __ ] going
oh yeah yeah yeah okay
why you like oh you over pronunciation
like your mouth goes so open when you
say it free
to be fair that was like i was still
figuring it out on tick tock
i'm a better musician than i am lip
singer well because i was
i was wondering maybe because like it's
hard to know what you're saying
sometimes so you want to like over
pronunciate so yeah
yeah i'm waiting for tick-tock to hit
you with the warning label
[Music]
a warning label oh for driving and
[ __ ] do not
film and drive at the same time that's
true they should put a warning label on
your video like when you say i am you
you pronunciate that [ __ ] big time boy
look at that again
i am a better musician and i am tick
tocker
hang on you want hang on here it is
who am i
[Laughter]
so anyway i thought it was fun if you
guys want to follow zach on tick tock
he's crushing it
i appreciate it i have no idea about
this
yeah zach remember that thing we had
planned later let's see let's cancel
that
yeah okay yeah
we were gonna vibe together uh tonight
um
yeah we're gonna vibe together i was
gonna make a cameo in his uh
oh my god are you guys cross uh
promoting your cameo
not no more i just had to change your
heart
oh is that why is that i don't want to
see it because we said zach is gonna
have to drive with someone and zach
immediately was like i'll go with av
we got a little thing yeah
yeah i went out
hey i'm just i'm just straight up vibing
man you've good vibes you know i'll i'll
drive for this one and you can record
yeah that's good get a little sex appeal
going on you know can you do one on the
freeway hitting a turn hard
and film it there
just try to make it look as unsafe as
possible
the funny thing i actually went to go
buy the cranberry juice
for the the dreams the fleetwood
you would have no hands you would have
one hand on the phone
man that i like to see no hands on the
wheel
you can see your driving in your glasses
no hands on the wheel
and i couldn't even do it because i have
to hold the drink and my boosted board i
need to control with the remote so
i just had to bail it it was too hard
[Laughter]
today on the 101 freeway he was drinking
cranberry and making a tick tock
he will be missed he went out vibin we
did
later find out he had a draft saved in
tick-tock he had a giraffe saved
he showed the final moments and the
reflection
i have a [ __ ] draft save that i will
never share man
oh really oh come on now you have to
have to
no you have to post it right now and
i'll pull it up
post it right now i don't know if it'll
be offensive or not man
it's like talking about a girl and i i
don't know i'll post it right now
okay fine thank you so much [ __ ] for
this
forget about it it's not live or
anything we can edit it out
this is exciting well if you made it you
clearly want to post it right is it
about your ads
no no no it's just it's just is it about
sniff
no no here how do i change here
i can't wait how do i [ __ ] change it
here while you do that i'll watch um
whatever the [ __ ] this
is
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he got electrocuted
[Laughter]
oh my god how do you think they keep the
grapes so juicy
they run a current through it that's
grape keeping 101
yeah jack your [ __ ] up
yeah it's posted oh baby did i bet it
oh here it is should we bet this um
maybe vet it first
is this it no we're not vetting it we're
going live
we're doing it i want a chicken out of
the oh for
[ __ ] sake hey what do you do for a
living
yeah a bad [ __ ] with no ass got him
what the [ __ ]
i think he's bad dude
[Laughter]
a bad [ __ ] with no ass got him
hey what do you do for a living
a bad [ __ ] with no ass
hey what do you do for a living
dude the delivery is crazy
the chick just seemed like such like
just an awful person and she's like not
that hot and it's like oh it's so
[ __ ] hard
hang on do we break this down or do we
just forget about it
[Laughter]
yeah a bad [ __ ] with no ass
the way you deliver the got him you're
like so
[ __ ] serious dude oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] no baby's dying man
i'm so glad we found it oh man
this is going to go viral i i should
have voted it
can i like it oh i liked it
holy [ __ ] dude
[Laughter]
you think you know a guy
[Laughter]
she thinks she's so [ __ ]
i hot it wasn't even a real video oh man
oh yeah cringe talk 101 right there
zach please keep making tick tock i'm
gonna get [ __ ] canceled
don't ever stop making tick tocks please
oh my god we gotta have a segment from
zapp's crafts
wow sex draft
[Laughter]
got him can you sound by yourself saying
got him
yeah yeah i'll do that
jesus man
oh [ __ ] oh
we're at an hour 43 uh
should we let's do the blackhead after i
finish this okay it's not going to work
what the [ __ ] shoplifter jumps three
stories and survives
stealing from forever 21. dude you're
risking your life for to steal from
forever 21.
it's not gonna help you bro you have to
drop
what you gonna do now bro dude for real
what you gonna do what you gonna do bro
you don't [ __ ] up bro forever 21
you're doing this
it looks like a kid maybe
world star
oh he's fine all right
he's like all right you deserve that
[ __ ] you deserve it you might want to
cut it after right now
yeah okay there's a lot of swearing in
the next part
okay cool he's like you deserve it i
kind of think he does too
oh my god damn
all right you want to do the blackhead
stuff is it time
is it time apparently trisha is coming
after james on tick tock right now
what is that trisha is coming after
oh she is oh let's pull it up she's like
going after him
let's go baby you know he's my you know
james my
come all over that james train wow
sister snapped
uh dude
zack you are the king of tick tock
don't man up okay so she's going after
james charles oh oh
i gotta say i really like her what are
you doing well in a second i'm gonna
bring it up could she play man
she pulls a lot you're setting up the
pimple things okay great
okay
what the [ __ ] is this this is your
content tricia seriously
i hate it high effort [ __ ] over here on
trisha paytas
right there yeah it does and this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] stephanie
freaking sue
stephanie sue eating her korean wings
and pizza
she's an absolute peach i love her
oh boring
while your girl is heated and i know a
lot of you guys are getting my treasure
also i want to get to the heat where's
the heat
where's the freaking heat oh here it is
here it is fun fact
actually really really sad back i've
actually never come from
someone i've never even met slash never
had any jobs
but the fact that this dude thinks
people should
keep his name he left a comment saying
keep my name out of your mouth to her
it did yeah she's in front of me you're
a
public figure yeah that's pretty wild
so [ __ ] twatty
condescending bratty wait i gotta get
all
she's got three oh she's got hearts baby
let's [ __ ] go
sister savage well
it says part two who starts on part two
you know what i'm saying
and so many other people your time is
coming
your cancellation is going to be insane
you're going to be the tyler oakley of
2020 where people
in front of yours will be like who oh
you know why he was a cocky little [ __ ]
too
and it's fine [ __ ] up make mistakes
being drama but own your [ __ ] don't act
like
you have the authority and the tell i'll
be i'll keep my name out of your mouth
so wait this must have been a reaction
to an old video she made about him
damn she's just ranting about everybody
on tick tock
can you try to find the first one ah
whatever
you just said keep my name out of your
mouth by the way who says that what is
he a [ __ ] like gangster
you know what i mean keep my name out of
your mouth sister
sister all right dan i mean it's not
that big of a deal dan's like trying to
run a spa in the bathroom
trying to give the full experience i'm
gonna
open up your pores yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna open up my pores
just for you guys i've got a warm towel
what's up
what's that this thing up
i have a warm towel on my face all right
you look like you're about to be
waterboarded i'm about to be
waterboarded
are we at full screen i think you gotta
make us full screen oh
okay it's not hot enough
but okay i did a little warm water there
i don't think it's visual like
all right so dan is going to work his
magic he's connecting the mainframe to
the blackhead remover we're hacking the
mainframe
right now
play hacking sounds please zack yeah if
you could
and like tense music
okay here's this okay
and now we're going to connect to this
device play like keyboard sounds
yeah zach uh yeah dan just hacked into
his own phone
cool we're on it and just like this
oh now we're in oh there it is there you
go
holy [ __ ] dude so i was thinking it'd be
funny to do
oh yeah it's wireless we have a wireless
like how crazy is it that we have a
wireless
camera like this like dan is really
something man
dan should be working for nasa not the
podcast
um i want to do a whole show like this
should i suck my eyeball so okay but
then okay so this one is going to get
gross so apologies to everybody
gross okay so you want the intensity so
when it gets really close
you can see everything right all this
stuff oh wow
yeah it's like really high quality oh
hair yeah it's disgusting that's my
beard
oh you think you have more facial hair
but you don't
wow that looks so gross yeah
and then when you get to part with like
pimples or like blackheads
oh my goodness there's my nose crazy
look that's my nose
looks horrific my forehead
back to my nose so i'm gonna turn it on
the thing is like watch this if i
suck it in so there's different uh
they're gonna hurt
[Music]
it doesn't hurt yet so i'm gonna put you
something is coming out i don't know if
that's just water
oil so the thing is if you leave it in
one spot too long
it
[Music]
it'll [ __ ] up it'll leave a mark like a
hickey on your nose
so i can't leave it in one spot this is
damaging my skin for sure this
in this tool
[Music]
oh my god it doesn't really suck it out
like they showed though you know
well you could leave it for a little
longer like on your nose
[Music]
no it's on the highest oh my goodness
[Music]
the thing is like i'm worried
you're worried for me dude you guys
should have done my nose you got some
string cheese
disgusting i mean nothing comes out of
my nose also maybe your
um maybe you didn't open it enough the
pores i gotta go take like a hot shower
maybe so gross
also when you move it ethan move it like
slowly because it's like the
the pressure of it kind of pushes up
[Music]
no i don't my skin's [ __ ] up
[Music]
yeah i see like white things
it feels so bad for my skin because it's
just because to pull it across you have
to like scrape it
yeah and you're not supposed to [ __ ]
scrape your skin
so let's try in the corner yeah i don't
think it's good for you
no there's no way this is good for you
so i'm at the corner here i'm at the
very corner of my nose can you show it
yeah we see the little camera
there we go now we're talking
so here's the thing look how little
there is actually there yeah
it looks massive on the camera oh that
looks so
gross
gave me i'm trying to clean it off to go
on for another round
really oh yeah you're so
brave you're doing stuff on camera well
what the [ __ ] do i care
everybody it's disgusting ew this is so
gross that it won't come out
ew i need like a q-tip or something yeah
okay i i cleaned it with a q-tip the
first time
this is the this is this is not the most
disgusting thing we've done
this isn't helping you smell the whole
phobia
this is a whole phobia
[Laughter]
you know who's loving this right now
sniff because she says she likes
pimple popping okay
so does my does my nose look [ __ ] up
like the crack where i sucked it right
here
no it looks more [ __ ] up here you have
a red mark
on your chair yeah let's see that right
there yeah
look how red it is you guys i'm trying
to find like the juicy parts of my face
that will work best your skin is really
pretty beautiful you i don't think
it'll work on you you you oh yes it was
it's going
you dude
oh it's going for sure oh oh for sure
that would make someone puke yeah this
is sick it wasn't mine
oh dude
oh my god oh we got a juicy um donation
you want to hear it
all caps james charles will be a
billionaire in a few years while h3h3
will flop
how many weeks you had his success your
50 year old
how much did they give us is that the
quartering
no was that the quartering
oh they actually the same person donated
another five dollars dude stop talking
about james he's
literally a celebrity you guys uh you
guys are nothing is this guy for real
you just hate donating
way quick keep talking about james
charles yeah
okay let me try to find a juicy part of
my nose again
[Music]
because like in the crack here i think
we got enough
oh and look it's really red already yeah
i [ __ ] up i swear to god
do it again i think i [ __ ] got my
skin permanently
it's interesting though to see i think
everyone's enjoying it i don't know what
they were enjoying
sniff said god i wish that was me
sucking ew
you are [ __ ] in the head girl yeah
oh my god that's like a youtube video
okay dude i have like a lag on the
close-up i'm so mad i can't see
i'm just hearing you guys reactions this
is so
we're going for it guys oh man it's
really coming now
it's so red [ __ ] it this is sick
it's for the show thick it really is
sick oh
there we go
[Music]
how bad does my nose look [ __ ] up on
camera
it's hard to tell in this lighting i i
have a feeling it's
more [ __ ] up than it seems yeah the
thing is i don't like shadow
from what i understood is that removing
blackheads is kind of a
for feudal endeavor because it just
comes right back and it damages your
skin
the crud on in the camera is so gross i
have to get rid of it
it is truly did you get any [ __ ] out
there when you did it no we're not done
are you serious yeah yeah not done i'm
gonna keep going
why it's for the show you don't have to
clean it
no it's disgusting but i'm trying
i'm trying to get the [ __ ] off the
corner of it
it is so gross turn it around ugh
that's on the inside though that's on
the inside
where's the good place where's the good
place to suck the schmutz out i did the
corners of my nose
yeah i mean i think that's the worst
part yeah the nose is the fastest part
usually
let me try my cheek or something deer
pubes
my pubes you guys want to see my dick on
this thing
i don't have many pores here actually i
feel like there's always [ __ ] here too
oh yeah but you're already left there
oh you can see all the it's like little
ones it's not coming though
yeah and that too this is sick
it's crazy seeing the individual hairs
yeah i hate it
this is a 40 device i think it was even
less
how much was it dan look it up okay
someone said ethan secretly hates us
so the people in the chat are so
sick nobody's leaving people no
i you don't even want to know what
they're typing right now tell me
taste it taste it no that's not
happening oh i would do that ethan
i'll do that for you okay dude there's
blood
oh there was a little blood but i
skipped right over it
i'm not tasting you sick animals yeah
that's
really sick i mean it's your home i
wonder i'm not tasting it it's just not
happening
i wonder if it would help your eyebrows
growing faster you wanna try on my
eyebrows
blow their hair out pull the hair out
who says that hd pockets doesn't have
the best content in the world
the quartering yeah the quartering good
qual
this is great content nobody's leaving i
thought everyone would leave but
like everybody's sticking around for
this somehow
right look how gross it is look on the
pipe look at the camera
i can't i'm trying to avoid it okay
here's my eyebrows
they compete in my basement oh i even
have blackheads in my
[ __ ] eyebrows that might just be it's
hairs
it's hairs oh it's new hairs coming in
yeah hair growth
yeah you want to see my dome here's my
dome
look at all the white hair by the way my
don't i have so much hairs on my head
but
like it doesn't look like it when you
get so close dude your hair is growing
like abnormally fast
dude it's been one week and it's like
normal that's not you guys want to see
in my ear
oh baby you're probably going to talk to
me actually
careful near your eardrum don't go do
you got back hair or anything
not too much ew
well here let me turn off the suck
because i don't want to lose my eardrums
so it's not sucking i just want to show
you guys down my ear hole
yeah i found it okay it was it was uh i
don't think we
want to see your ear i was wrong it was
forty five dollars
forty five dollars ew like this is
inside my ear guys it looks like a house
it's my tight little ear hole
oh do you want to play make ethan laugh
oh yeah we have to play make geekingthan
laugh i forgot
okay we're at two hours just well i'm
still really into this do that
zach get someone quick this is behind
right here oh [ __ ] this is behind my
ears
[Applause]
oh my lord
you dude oh my god what was that
hold on i'm really into this it's pretty
entertaining i think
it's entertaining me anyway this is my
other ear
blood started to come out it's just a
tiny bit but it looks like so much
but it's like just it's not even a drop
how do i take this off i have to clean
this down i can't go on like this
does this screw off oh yeah there's more
okay
oh are they just all one size fits all
yeah oh
no oh for real
yeah oh well let's get the [ __ ] the
death grip one this one's
big and so small here this is a death
grip one what was the one i just used
oh it's like a okay let's try what's the
smallest hole i want a death grip
ew dude that was crazy
this one looks pretty interesting i have
someone lined up when you guys already
maybe you can do it while i'm doing the
tempo
oh this is this really is something i
got
okay i can't believe i just sucked blood
out of my ear
let's try this one this is sick
this one feels like there's not much
going on in my nose there
here's my forehead
[Music]
hero going in my mouth oh no
okay this one's clean
it's my tongue oh it's clean i was like
how are you not disgusted yeah
don't do this don't do it
what are you doing stop
you wanna see my butthole yeah i wanna
see that
here's my belly button you're damaging
yourself
no don't cut it down all right they're
saying this is too far
i'm over it i think we're officially on
but i need a different one okay no we're
officially off i'm not done
it's so cool can we vote
okay get out
okay are you going in the nose oh yeah i
see the boogies dude
yeah baby you can see the buggies
what is that yeah what is that sort of
crossbeam
that's a bug really i don't feel a bug
that crazy
disgusting hi everybody hi guys
i think everyone is ready for you to be
over
[Laughter]
look at this this is awesome what
you can see my face and then it's like
no no no no oh
[Laughter]
all right let's do ethan left okay thank
you okay
i have uh anthony who wants to try his
stand-up routine on you
wow wow bold oh that was so
gross my skin feels like it was
chemically
like i feel more like greasy
you know you feel crazy yeah because
that's crazy
well pulled the grease out right and he
is on the line
now all right anthony are you with us
hello anthony you're a comedian uh
aspiring comedian
whoa cool yeah man um
i'm trying to put you on speaker but
it's not working very well speaker's
probably
not a good idea right dan yeah i mean
if if you can avoid it but really we
just need to listen to you
so um so no worries well anthony tell me
about yourself how long you been doing
stand up
hey man i've been i actually just
started stand up uh
yesterday i see so i'm pretty new at it
yeah it sounds like it how did it go how
did your first set go
well this is gonna be my first set oh
you started yesterday and this is your
first performance
yeah this is my first performance in
front of a wide audience
um i gotta say i'm probably
i would say i'm your biggest fan and
this is probably the
second most exciting moment in my life
whoa what's the what's the first
the first oh i was uh standing well the
first would be what that time i stood in
line behind a casey neistat at an adult
bookstore
oh i can see why that would be really
exciting
yeah do you want to know what he was
buying you look bomb today
i'm just looking in the camera you look
all dark and like you look like a uh
slither slithender slip
slip
are you making a harry potter yeah thank
you what is it
you look like a sexy slytherin thank you
yeah anyway i'm sorry what was casey
neistat buying
you were in you say you saw him in an
adult
like a adult like a porn shop bookstore
yeah it's like a bookstore they only
sold like adult books like sexy books
and casey neistat was in there buying
uses buying candy
he was buying a bag of fun sizes that
kind of sounds like casey but what you
does
okay and then and then did you say
anything to him why was that
it seems like this should if that was
the most excited you've ever been
i feel maybe even if you like casey more
than me that maybe
this maybe could take number one in some
way
yeah he was buying um and i was getting
a box of mike and ikes
all right well based on your
storytelling abilities um
i'm not expecting to laugh through this
so do you want to take it away
okay you have sure yeah yeah are you all
ready you have 60 seconds all right dan
is going to tell you when to go i wish
you the best of luck if you can make me
laugh
thank you you got a hundred dollars so
thank you and good luck all right here
we go in three
two one go all right so my love life has
been
pretty dull lately um i started taking
viagra for that
um not for sex i just find it endlessly
empowering to go about my daily errands
with a raging
diamond cutter
i've got more
oh god sorry
i'm driving hey you're driving can it
i'm driving right now you're ruining my
moment with ethan and iwa
is this a [ __ ]
awesome this guy's pulling up now
hey dude i'm sorry man
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
i think that was fact i know i didn't
know
and he got you right on the water that
was at like 59 seconds yeah he did make
me laugh wow
is he there though or did he bounce no i
mean he's still in the channel
but it sounded like he had some sort of
encounter yeah
i think yeah and now he's gone i think
he's gone
i was just like wow he put in because i
know he did this whole bit
and everything which is funny but the
fact that he programmed didn't talk to
me baby
but they kind of get you did get me well
antonio i actually
i was also laughing at the whole bit
with the car
yeah i don't know where it was going but
it was funny
yeah well i don't know he's gone he had
a car shopping
he's not in the channel anymore i don't
know what the [ __ ] happened all right
all right well if you want
a hundred dollars you did earn it so uh
i was like no way this guy's gonna make
me laugh yeah i really didn't think that
was going anywhere
should we do some more we have a few
more let's do some more
oh no we have a kelsey
or kaylee god my nose feels so [ __ ] up
she wanted to say thanks for all the
goofs and laughs
my mom passed away recently and i don't
have much family outside of that so
getting to sit with you all
has meant so much peace and love
so he's in love that's sad but peace and
love peace and love
peace and love thank you so much should
we do more
make ethan laugh or just end it we can
do one more
do we have one more lined up let's set
it up yeah we do let me know
with peace and love should i do more
blackhead [ __ ]
no i think it's shut down
there is one uh here so horrible that i
don't know if i want to read it but
oh don't read that oh
oh yeah no that i mean someone said mary
[ __ ] mary kill i thought it said i will
kill three people i was like uh
[Laughter]
no so they're saying [ __ ] mary kill
james charles
king star or matt haas the problem with
this game is that
everybody's looking to [ __ ] like
expose me so
if i say i'm going to kill anybody then
they'll be like like the quartering like
that's true ethan says he's going to be
like five videos
yeah yeah but let me rephrase it i'll
say
obviously i want to [ __ ] james charles
because that ass is so fat
i mean uh mary
i can't play this game yeah i just want
to [ __ ] james charles that's all i know
i have uh montana mode
montana mode hello
yo tell me about yourself what's good
montana
uh my name is dimitri i'm from australia
i just moved just moved to l.a
oh welcome fashion design college very
cool
[Music]
so you have do you have a do you think
you're going to be able to make me laugh
today
i'll do my best see what i can do all
righty then
all right hey i have a question uh
uh are you waiting for a mate or i don't
know what's it there
yeah i'm just waiting for a minute is
that is that clip famous in
australia that's probably like one of
the biggest viral videos
oh that's awesome that one and then have
you seen like the the barking dog guy
oh yeah yeah yeah he came bounding over
yeah yeah that guy's wild huh what's up
you know what's up
so that's pretty awesome so if you walk
around in australia for the most part
if you like you're hanging out with
savvy people and you say
i just wait for a mate people know
i wonder if that guy if that guy can
even walk around without getting
recognized because he's a very
recognizable face and they showed his
face a lot
yeah but i mean i feel like if he may be
shaved a little bit away grew his hair
out you know
yeah is there some fun slang we can
learn to today australian slang
yeah well there's a lot like a lot of
australian slang is people
just like shorten a lot of words so like
right
so like instead of saying like like
service station
like like gas station let's just say
servo or like um
or like uh i'm having a blank but we
just do a lot of that like my name is
three people just call me people just
call me dimmy yeah yeah exactly
hey have you heard this expression i i
think it's an a kiwi expression but
maybe you've heard of it
they say rattle your dags when they want
you to hurry up
that sounds pretty uh uh sound that
sounds like something we'd be saying
so apparently apparently in new zealand
they have a bunch of sheep there
and a lot of the sheep get
[Laughter]
yeah dingleberries a lot of australians
will call uh
uh new zealanders there's a bit of a
derogatory term they call them sheep
[ __ ]
because there's so many sheep there yeah
you know
apparently there's some i wouldn't say
animosity but some
some some friendly banter between the
two countries or is there animosity
well i thought that there was like
nothing really until one day i was
talking to my dad about it and he was
like oh yeah back in
because my dad's pretty old he's like
72. and he was like yeah back in the day
though
people really hate like they hated each
other but now it's just like
people like americans a lot of americans
think we're the same bloody country like
i get that
i get that question all the time well
you don't even know what rattle the dags
are
all right here's a good one wait here's
a good one um um um fair shake of the
source bottle you ever heard that one
say that again no
a fair shake of the sauce bottle sauce
bottle no what is that
yeah like as in like a ketchup it just
means like uh uh
give somebody a fair chance hmm a fair
shake it's like egg
fish take the sauce bottle oh my ketchup
bottle for the entire
fair shake at the sauce bottle
bottle man hey but do you know what
rattle so they got these dingleberries
all the sheep and they got
when they're saying hey hurry up they
say rattle your dags like when a sheep
blocks yeah
it's rattling together it's like [ __ ]
hilarious
that's funny as [ __ ] that is funny all
right all right cool
are you ready uh story yeah all right
dan's going to tell you when to start
one minute here we go in three two one
go
okay so i used to work at a department
store
and in the first week working there was
around christmas
time we couldn't really go and have
bathroom breaks that much so when you
did you have to like run in and run out
kind of and like be kind of quick
because it was like
like around shopping time at christmas
and what happened was
i uh uh the bathrooms are really small
like they're not like public bathrooms
they're like personal ones and they have
one stall and one urinal
and i was using the urinal and there was
a guy in the stall
and just out of like instincts when i'm
leaving a small bathroom like at home if
there's a
if there's a light switch right next to
the door i'm just going to instinctively
turn it off
so as i was walking out i turned it off
while this guy was in the stall and
i was like so embarrassed that i just
didn't even go and turn it back on for
him
so just sitting in the dark
i'm on my good gangsters let me get a
laugh come on oh i thought they were but
like
that's a funny premise for sure
and that's well yeah yeah
yeah fair enough i think you were
expecting like like something to do with
[ __ ] or something because it had to do
with about right that's what it got me
for sure
yeah yeah yeah exactly did you guys
what's up where are you keep going keep
going sorry i should say all the
previous winners had to do with
feces yeah yeah exactly that's why i was
like yeah i got a toilet story but
yeah i was like i'll try it out but um
uh one last thing before i leave do you
guys say that you're doing an among us
stream with gus johnson
yes we already filmed it well we did it
yeah we did it with
us eddie video game donkey and leah and
yeah and the whole gang so there's 10 of
us and it's coming awesome
well ian's working on it right now so oh
awesome well big shout out to gus
because in the
manga stream with an id that he just did
he was wearing my uh t-shirt from my
t-shirt brand
oh no wait what's your t-shirt um
it's uh montana mode look it up on
instagram it's the same as my discord
name
and then mode and montana mode
i'm looking it up right now now you've
got what it's doing your brand montana
mode
is that technically cultural
appropriation of american
well it's called it's just called
montana but i named it after my friend
and her name is
oh okay i don't know why i'm not finding
here montana mode
look it up on instagram yeah and then a
lot of that stuff right there that's a
lot of older stuff but at the moment i'm
working on a lot of like cut and so like
really you know hands-on stuff so i'm
having a bit of a break but i'm gonna
i'm gonna send you some pictures of my
send us some stuff
how did you get your stuff to uh gus
um i just uh sent it to him and i knew
he'd like the t-shirt design that i had
that's pretty awesome
nice and his warning yeah he wore it in
his uh he wore it in his um
he wore it in his about podca in his own
podcast with uh
the episode that he had william osman on
and also his brothers wanted
a couple of his videos dude what are
your nice guys that's crazy cool
yeah yeah that's super nice i'm trying
to find it i want to show it
but i don't know where
montana mode or or like the websites
actually not
the instagram's probably better but have
a look at the instagram montana mode
one word and then instagram that's what
i typed oh i put maid
[ __ ] me
here i just here oh my god i'm getting
so many followers thank you so much
here it is montana mode okay
is this you uh the
the first guy that's so jeezy that's a
famous rapid that's my friend
oh cool oh okay yeah yeah yeah
um but yeah thank you very much
montana has a mobility scooter you make
me a mobility
a mobility scooter shirt and i'll rock
that
oh well okay no just because you said
that i'm going to do that 100
100 i'm doing that today and i'm going
to send it to you i'm putting in the
t-shirt and everything all right
and just for you okay well thank you
very much all right dude take care good
luck
goodbye bye all righty
that's uh that's a wrap that's a wrap
thank you guys for watching i had a lot
of fun here today my nose hurts you're
listening to the hp
god this guy thanks guys you don't want
me man
now you guys know i just i have a hard
time wrapping these things up you know
that so i'm just trying to dip out
trying to pull that band-aid off
one last shout out to lala for another
five dollar donation
uh i think james has bad luck with 50
euros trying to ruin his career you and
hila continue to have your hands dragon
james yeah what the
well i don't know that they're members
somehow i doubt that they're members
although they've given us like steady
dollars commented
don't you have to be no no
listen the song's ending i'm desperate
to get a hold of this person that's all
so
so right dan or whatever i just want to
know who you are
okay all right love you guys see you
next week
tata from tati there's pete in my
basement
ttyl
finn talking front wiper back wife what
you gonna do
with me then you know and the whole damn
crew
goosing gaps with all the guests you'll
see the best pocket